tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono video
sono fa dj oggi se non lo sapete ve lo
dico io e venerdì 13 quindi non potevo
non fare e wings hanno sbagliato schermo
poi ci fa che io sono tutto che si
impegna rifacciamo signori oggi è di 13
quindi si fa questo molto molto dovrei
organizzarmi meglio prima ragazzi
quest'oggi siamo contro jason voorhees
riccardo milos che saluto tomato gusto
man
vabbè redhawks e l'all boys 98 si parte
farò così scrive qua io sono jason
colloca maschera blu c'era solo sto qua
quindi occhio e poi sono caparezza come
personaggio consiglio gli animatori
dovrebbero collaborare provento le
probabilità di sopravvivenza si se non
fossero tutti russi armeni tedeschi
sarebbe più facile però se come non ci
capiamo non gioco a vela di 13 da quando
abbiamo fatto la live non so se la
ricordate quella dove abbiamo battuto il
record di quasi 200 mila iscritti in un
giorno da ecco forse solo i nocese un po
essere sai eravamo solo in due questa
maschera quindi o sono io e l'altro
attenzione potrei essere io a bataille
va davvero incredibile sono solo gesù va
bene e per una volta sono un po
scontento di esserlo perché la tav come
da un po che non gioco sono molto
arrugginito quindi magari non era
massimo prendere subito gente ma va bene
non fa niente andiamo subito a vedere se
ciò che se riusciamo a mettere le
trappole nella macchina speriate
sperando che ce ne sia solo una di
macchina allora vediamo non sono molto
esperto ragazzi come jason ma si vede
che viene acquisto venditrici ha voluto
omaggiare mi ci sono due macchine
andrei subito in questa perché quella
più vicino alle case più visti tua visto
tutto visto portarci tua batteria del
visto
brutta pezzente di nicole mamma mia che
schifo
cosa vuoi fare questa roba cosa vi fa
vuoi mettere l'acqua davanti mi dispiace
se ti piaccio questa bellissima roba
così tu la trappola non la metti c'era
la barberia attenzione che ti vedo e non
spuntare che ti vedo arriva dove c'è
vita di andarmene poi lancia un
coltellaccio pan ma bravissima ma si sa
che è stata veramente brava si è
spostata mi sento che fate bordello guai
usa l'altra porta ma io so quello che
voglio mi sento che fate bordello qua
dentro non sto controllando l'altra
macchina ragazzi non è il massimo questa
cosa però adesso devo far fuori questo
qua se riesco non entrò poi a sinistra
vediamo se riesco l'ente eccolo ciao zio
buongiorno vieni qua 123 vediamo timore
prima mi ha tolto la maschera come come
mano tutto no fermi come hai fatto volo
ammazzata prima nome ragazzi un bug
questo ma sono shrek
come ha fatto ma se che non è possibile
la maschera se la si può togliere solo
con ma hanno cambiato questa dp giuro
non pensavo si potesse fare così subito
d'orario
madonna ragazzi non lancerò michael
thonet vita mia faccio schifo a lanciare
i coltelli ma veramente io comunque
ragazzi una cosa non la capisco come ha
fatto a togliermi la ma guarda questa è
la faccia di jason ce l'ho vista ho mai
capito solo una volta rivederla pazzesco
ma vabbè dai è fratello dove vai
cosa temo che la cosa non è il russo è
tornato l'ucraina era russo quello lico
è possibile come fa quindi adesso si
possono disabilitare le trappole tutte
salve quelle fatte quando non gioco da
un po
porca vacca to sorella non so se hanno
messo la batte la roma io tanto di
alimentata dalla propria attenzione
della finestra parali che volta
bellissimo baciala in testa fortissimo
gela bellissimo sono diventato il check
in on a chi porta i boston a le boe
adesso li prendo tutti i coltelli briano
è beccato uno o incredibile questo
faccio il trasferimento veloce mia sisca
incastrare questa è andata bene o dove
con la macchina che si è abbassata 15 ci
penso io vi preoccupate non si salvano
preoccupate non si salvano ciao zio
allora aspetta che vedo che stanno da
prendono ovviamente un palo peso piccola
sono scemi
lo sa perché stanno tagliando per il
traguardo ei do mai era l'altra del
corso dove si dovrà sommare va bene
daitarn dato tutto bene stato tutto di
culo non fa niente intanto mi butto
dovranno accalappiato e vediamo se
scabec a qualcosa tipo wonder woman che
è rimasta fuori
chi è che si è salvato ma ancora non ha
dato che sono fuggiti o si fugge tease
in due
riccardo milos è fuggito ha lasciato qua
che te devo dire io ci ho provato a
dirlo varie c'è stata
babbo veramente orribile sta cosa ci
puoi seguire la gente sta cosa qua mi
mette un ansia è schiattati dovrai
questi quali tengo come se non ci fosse
un domani ragazzi tanto la trappola lo
piazzata sull'altra macchina ed è
difficile che fuggano gli altri ce li
vedrà i ragazzi li ho visti un'altra
macchina sta partendo ma sa che non so
se andare contro di loro contro la
macchina è una scelta ragazzi ha
valutato prova a sfondare vediamo se
funziona ma la tipa adesso andrà fuori
però non ha visto il ciarra paul non
l'ho presa a cavallo posizionata male
pensavo di poterla prendere amaci a
fuggire questa
aysun resisti resisti a cosa ha la mia
madre mi stava parlando per qualche
motivo domandata la macchina è ancora
qui l'attenzione qualcosa sta prendendo
gli altri ma avanzato il fucile bravo
tanto adesso vi fregate più sotto per
l'uscita brave e ti sta incastrando
madonna ragazzi ragazzi non scappate più
di mezzo dove l'uscita però bella sta
partita ragazze a e adrenalinica dov'è
andata la macchina ragazzi non si scappa
di là beh come io spiego domandata la
macchina mai visto adesso si può
scappare anche dall'altra parte hanno
raggiunto cose che non sapevo maraga
prima potevi scappare o da una parte
dall'altra e subisca parla tutte e due
ma diavolo non lo sapevo questa cosa
e vabbè ma non vale che fatto tutte ste
cose quando quando non gioco io varco
demonio anno non va
cioè si sono salvati i primi due si sono
salvati bene queste due si sono salvati
perché non sapevo questa cosa porco
demonio non avevo idea ma proprio non lo
sapevo non pensavo ti potessi che
potesse scappare da tutte e due le parti
una volta tanto giocavo io non era così
li mortacci vostri tanto sfondata la
porta con se non ci fosse un domani la
donna faceva troppo la ricordavo che una
lava piazzata non so dove
quello si è buttato voi ma io posso
sfondarla con la testa le porta non lo
sapevo sta roba
tant andiamo da quello e vabbè ma questi
come si salvano è difficile non si sta
muovendo porca vacca purtroppo raga mi
dispiace per sta roba qua
cavolo non pensavo potessero fuggire a
tutto per le parti ce l'avevo in pugno
peccato porco demonio l'avessi saputo
prima vedete avete visto che era me lo
sapevo che non dovevo essere genoa la
prima partita dovevo capire le modifiche
che avevamo fatto nel mentre ragazzi la
caccia finale su tommy jarvis che il
primo che aveva ucciso
ok è tornato in vita subito mi dispiace
cavolo la metà si sono salvati potevi
salvarti pure ed è però non canto
vittoria non è detto magari chiama
batman 66 nascoste dietro l'albero dove
sarà mai non ti ho visto dove che sarà
andato qui dentro sei fratello ma dai
che se fai il bruto che casino frate
vieni qua non hai capito chi con chi
stai giocando non andare nella con andrè
nella comanda nell'acqua saresti un
pazzo 12
l'ho visto un paio di volte morto
e vabbè ma dai ma non puoi far a
coltellate contro jazz oppure idee non
puoi fare a coltellate contro jason e
vabbè è ormai morto non può scappare più
lo sai che sei morto bellissima la morte
è morto è esploso tre su otto in realtà
sono quattro ma semplicemente un
alettato mi dispiace che la metà sono
fuggiti perché non sapevo io di questa
cosa mannaia però in tutto questo jason
senza la maschera belli avrei fatto 6 su
8 porco demonio e una partita bellissima
vece una partita media mannaia la morte
vabbè peccato quattro su otto ragazzi
onesto presso una partita che era da un
po che non facevo bellissima può avere
di 13 a tutti poter andar meglio poteva
andar peggio quindi nice
ricordatevi jason alla porta se sono io
occhio commesso le trappole un bacino e
scegliamo al prossimo episodio di
venerdì 13
very soon dai ragazzi scrive di
schiacciate la campanellina dimetta
giocatrici video vediamo al prossimo
video bella acu c è anche quest'uomo qua
sempre bellissima però con la maschera
più e meglio
[Musica]